what up my name d smoke i'm from
inglewood california and check me out on
the bootleg calf podcast
yo it's the bullet cap podcast bullet
cap show special guest
d smoke yes sir welcome
hey congrats on this album thank you
warren wonders
uh first of all the the cover is
incredible the artwork is incredible
you're always so good when it comes to
details i always tell everybody like
you got the best videos the best
coloring the best concepts like you know
i know you put so much into just the
details of what you do absolutely um
give me uh
why the name warren wonders what's the
what's the the background behind that
and kind of dive into the story of the
artwork
um
war wonders is that project that's about
showing the world the two sides of what
it means to be a youngster from
inglewood who
is pushing the line on both fronts you
know what i'm saying on one side
um
i got a heart for the streets you know
my big brother grew up in the street
element a little bit more than we did
and we were we were there but by the
time we were coming up as teenagers you
know pops was in the house as little
kids my pops was locked up so we was
fighting during the whole night he come
home
and we're more so like
a little bit more straight and narrow
but still
you know parents can't afford to drive
you everywhere so he's still catching
the bus we in this in the actual streets
of inglewood so
um
warren wonders is that
we're familiar with this
but it's
you know for the sake of arriving at
that place where you can look around and
be proud of where you are what you've
gotten so you can't
experience the wonders in life if you're
not willing to confront and experience
the war you know so it's just that
duality of being d smoke that i wanted
to share and then what about the cover
because the cover seems like there's a
big message behind the coverage as well
yeah absolutely so um of course one of
my main
values is other than family is community
you know what i'm saying so
uh that picture represents
the community that puts you all the
different elements like you know from
the uh the girl with her hair wrapped
with the rollers and her hair blowing
the bubble to the girl with the booty
shorts on to you know homies with the
wave cap durax flip flops the bottle the
the speaker the the lolo bike is just
like
we get some of everything in the
community that all contributes to who
you are as a person and that's lifting
me up to you know
uh to be able to you know the symbolism
of breaking that chain
um
and it's an actual gold chain that's
kind of shaped like a new so it's just
all those symbolism that
uh that represent all the people that it
really takes for any one person to be
free you feel me do you feel like
because i feel like you know like when
you listen to the album like you talk
about like you know
gang banging over turf that you don't
own or dirt you don't own right
absolutely do you feel like that that
was like those kind of messages weren't
being presented to your generation for
the kids who were from where you were
from like and like maybe you're kind of
setting a new because i feel like
there's so much game in a lot of the
[ __ ] you're saying
there's so many lines and i'm like man
there's some real grown man like
ill [ __ ] but like that line like how
important is that for you to kind of
you know when it comes to you're from
inglewood you know what i'm saying and
obviously when you're from l.a gang
culture is
omnipresent absolutely even if you're
not in it and when you're in hollywood
when you're in downtown everywhere
everywhere yeah 100 right so like
you know
there's it's it's it's hard to be the
guy to be like hey you shouldn't gang
bang
because you don't know the story behind
hey did someone lose a brother or a
cousin or whatever but at the same time
like there's
there's got to be a middle ground where
you know absolutely well let me i'll put
it this way gangbanging isn't
uh being a member of a gang let's say
that isn't wrong
you know what i'm saying it's the it's
the culture
not the overall culture it's the
activity it's how it's done it's the
lack of connection between the big
homies who know better and the young
homies who got something to prove you
know and
and that's just not again it's not just
a gang banging thing because outside of
gangbanging in other cities we still
find the violence we still find of
course the same problems
it's just a community thing a culture
thing first and then um
[Music]
so i have i have a heart for people like
i feel like
it's human instinct to connect to build
to form organizations to or you know
outside of gangbanging in africa we had
tribes you know what i'm saying and one
tribe over here might not get along with
the tribe over here so it's not me
preaching against gang banging it's more
so
preaching against the ignorance that
makes us organizing
uh
them versus us type thing you know what
i'm saying like why
i'm not i'm not a gang member
but why do i feel the need to keep a
pistol on me you know what i'm saying
well you said that you have a five-mile
you go through five different
neighborhoods on your commute commute
yeah and the kids and the kids who
you're teaching don't realize that you
you got you got it you got a piece on
you come on period mm-hmm period true
story you know and um
that's because like i taught i taught on
well i taught several places one i was
teaching close to home when i taught at
inglewood
then i taught at westchester and that of
course you heading west you're not
passing through too many hoods like that
outside of inglewood and then um but it
was when i taught on vermont and 60th
coming from century and la brea that
it's like okay i'm out of this
neighborhood in inglewood through these
other three neighborhoods in inglewood
through you know what i'm saying
you know the a trade through the you
know it's like all these different hoods
well forbid you have to stop and get gas
come on now
we get gas on our side right right right
before you get in there you know and um
and
and then of course there's an exception
to every world i've stopped to get gas
in another hood you know and you
you kind of hope that somebody ain't
having a bad enough day to where they're
not listening to reason or that or to
where they don't ask no questions at all
you know because that happens it had
been times where it was like they just
pulled up and start busting that's
tragic you know but then there's been
times where i'd have been pressed and i
could tell he looking at me like waiting
for me to say the wrong thing and i
could tell he got a gun on him like hand
all tucked and everything and i'm like
you know what i'm saying and it's just a
matter of
you know have you mastered yourself
enough to be to look them in the eyes
and be like i'm solid bro i hope all is
well which you know and just let them
make that decision to be like do i want
to do do i want to do a good human being
harm and i think even behind all the
gang stuff there's there's this
people have to be triggered or pushed
over that little edge and sometimes fear
of pushing being scary will push people
over the edge
you know it'll
trigger that uh
that instinct that predatory instinct if
you look like oh two should be oh i got
him i got him whereas if it's like no
all is well bro god bless you you know
but it's direct it's like i'm not scared
of you but i'm looking into you like
i know i know what you got you know what
i'm saying and if you're gonna do it
you're gonna have to live with the fact
that you did it in the wrong situation
you know because fear tells on a lot of
people some people are afraid because
they know they might be on the bad side
of some well-deserved karma they might
have done something similar out there ah
you know that's not my story so if you
gonna pull up
if you're gonna pull up and bust on d
smoke you're gonna bust on somebody that
is proud of what he did
done right by his family and his
business partners and i'ma look you in
your eyes like damn is this that because
we all got our day you feel me like and
i don't it's not that i want to go but
it's like i i've
seen i've been in those situations where
it could have been that you know so and
and a lot of so much is outside your
control so like you're referring to uh
find my way
you know in so many ways it's like
we're all navigating as a teacher i'm
still navigating i'm navigating like
like the law won you know what i'm
saying california is it's hard to have a
gun you know what i'm saying i'm
navigating the law i'm navigating uh
you know going in there wanting to be
effective with the kids but i'm in the
middle of the hood and it's a lot
working against me just a mindset you
know
so
um so yeah this this album kind of shows
shows both of that and and and it shows
love to the people it's like people got
to forgive themself like they be hard on
themselves like man i ain't got it
figured out but and that's okay so
that's the thing fighting my way it's
like we all out here trying to find that
or find our way and once we think we
found it we still navigate that's real
[ __ ] you said some ill [ __ ] uh you had a
line where you said that your wife drove
you to sanity
my wife came in my life drove me to
sanity which i think is dope because
again i'm married but i i feel like we
don't hear enough about you know the
benefits of having a solid woman behind
you absolutely absolutely
it's
how much honesty are people willing to
give you know and not just honesty
vulnerability you know because uh what
was that it was a superman movie was it
a superman movie or somebody referred to
a superman
saying you know leave clark kent at home
don't bring lois lane into the workplace
you know what i'm saying because that's
what people
uh predators will exploit you know what
i'm saying they see the strong chest and
they're like oh i can't penetrate that
armor but i could grab her
and make you
been bend the need to to uh
you know what i'm saying to save
somebody that you care about and in the
same sense i feel like rap has that
tendency we show up with our strongest
self you know what i'm saying yeah and
then
lo and behold we got somebody that's
loving us into strength you know what
i'm saying in all honesty so um
but yeah i said my life my wife came in
my life drove me to sanity distinguish
between the swedish and vanities coffee
no cream of killing me softly i need an
energy call me old fashioned but in the
canopy
i'll be getting what these hoes promise
and can't deliver
ain't got no canvas won't paint a
picture
ain't got no time for that faint
attempts my little house is straight
made of bricks climbed the mountain and
made a river you know so it's like it's
just the truth of it and and not that
i'm imposing that view on anybody like
if you ain't found that person don't try
to make the wrong personality for sure
that's a huge mistake don't do that yeah
i'm saying like don't do that [ __ ] yeah
you know and uh
and i think even prior to finding her i
think we're all a little bit guilty of
like because we got our hopes up that we
got somebody you know um
but
but yeah so that's that's a little bit
of like straight honesty
like like you know there's something to
be said about like um being in a
relationship where
it's not
taxing on your mental
and i can only imagine
with where you are in your career right
being on the road or i don't know that
pandemic kind of probably halted a lot
of your travel but you did go to africa
right i did i did go to um i mean in
your your profile is a lot more higher
and i mean
in any relationship
your specific set of circumstances might
make
you know
any relationship a little bit more
difficult at times absolutely so it
takes a special kind of woman
to
not add any [ __ ] to your plate while
you're trying to
bd smoke absolutely
absolutely some of that comes from
uh
just confidence
you know like and and
confidence doesn't negate a woman's need
to be reassured right you know what i'm
saying any woman is gonna because the
reassurance is not in it's not just in
her being reassured in herself it's
reassured
in your intent how present you are your
actions and your feelings
you know the fact that your feelings
haven't changed you have to reassure
them of that you know what i'm saying so
um that's some real [ __ ] man but when
you have to but when somebody needs
reassurance of who they are
it's different then they've put you in a
position that you nobody deserves to be
in because you can say all the things in
the world but if you're not happy with
you it don't matter from you it gotta
come from you so
um
but
but yeah you you definitely need
somebody that's confident that is sure
in himself
and and
bold enough to be honest when it's not
well something's not well yeah that's
real you know and that's you got to be
that too you know the the
responsibilities on both sides there's
additional work on my part
and on my wife's part to
maintain something that
that is true and strong and can
withstand little stuff you know what i'm
saying
it's it's no secret that
women on the internet are gonna be like
that's my husband that never met me you
know what i'm saying and you got to just
brush that off
you know yeah nah i mean i feel like
yeah cause especially when you were when
the show first came out there was
[ __ ] was like i mean it was going
crazy respectful young ladies
were loving you they were going crazy no
it was going crazy yeah it went nuts i
mean [ __ ] in the most respectable way
possible we know what you mean
beautiful independent yes timely yeah
you know creative yeah i'm just kidding
um
yo you you just announced the tour right
before you got here right i did just how
many dates is it it's like it's 22. man
that's big
and i know that i wanted to be 33 but
there had to have been a black habits
tour that was supposed to happen it was
cooked we actually
we had those dates reserved for the
black habits not these exact dates now
but we had those all of those venues
already lined up and then a pandemic
just [ __ ] everything up we literally
um
you know uh cordee hit me up because
even before we released black habits all
i had was inglewood hyatt right but we
had that moment and a strong following
and the songs from rhythm and flow and
he was like bro uh come on tour with me
the lost boy tour yes
and he did some dates in january so it
was he hit me end of december like top
of the year you hopping out and i was
like bro i'd love to but we we're
closing out a project right now he's
like say less i understand
you know and you know we still put out
black habits and black habits did what
it did you know so there's no regrets
here but it's like
damn is there any world where we still
put it out and you will because the
world exactly because the world's about
to shut down we go outside like all
right one last time we only got one
month we can hop out and pop out
especially you know with chordae
incredible artists that i respect like
how he approaches you know creativity
his music himself 100 he's one of the
best man one of the greatest way
way early like to be his age and to be
doing it like that it's like it's dope
to watch who i like who else is another
artist or two that um
are your peers uh that inspire you man
i'm not talking about the ogs because
it's easy to say snoop or dre or whoever
i mean like you know your peers man
you're just a couple man um
just because i can't i don't distinguish
between like singing and rapping and
stuff like that right of course just
music like
this me knows
you know the sabbah is crazy crazy you
know uh mesego is crazy those are my
guys and then i'm from cali so i'm just
i like hood [ __ ] too so you know what
i'm saying g parriko the homie i always
look out for what he's doing yeah he's
in the video yeah g rico the homie you
know
um you know what i'm saying rj he in the
video too they're my dogs but when they
put some out i'm listening because they
got the
thumb on the on the pulse of the streets
you know
um
but but it's this you know and then it's
just music that i'm just you know i love
i love like soulful [ __ ] uh like alex is
like you know what i'm saying and so
um but yeah
do you feel like uh i feel like on this
album like
as as lyrical as a genius you are i
think you really press press the pedal
down on on just wrapping your ass off on
this project like
um what was your approach this being
your sophomore album like we talked a
little bit earlier i think definitively
it's better than black habits black
habits will get to the grammy nomination
which was a big deal
but what was your approach like your
mind's stake going into recording this
album that was different from black
habits because black habits like you
said
the show happens you already have
inglewood high was already out right
that's your first
project
coming out off the tv show you know and
now you're established you got through a
pandemic you know what was your mind
state recording this one
this one um it's just a lot of real life
frustrated energy in this one and i
think that makes for
good art you know like i was really
i'm pushing myself because i want to
translate the turmoil that's happening
inside
plus it's still the joy of
where i'm fortunate enough to be in life
what i've been able to accomplish in a
short amount of time after a long amount
of time you know what i'm saying i've
been at it for a long time within these
two years two and a half years of crazy
you know so
so but it's like the
in inner turmoil is like damn why would
i have this big this big opportunity you
know i got faith i'm i come from a
god-fearing household so it's like god
why are you gonna give me all this and
shut the world down like let me go
outside you know what i'm saying like
so for that to happen
um it's like some of them
some of those songs come from that
energy but it's like
you're frustrated but you still know who
you are so you're going to give them
that energy back it's like in inglewood
like before i had a grip of money i
still knew that inside it was something
that that distinguished me from what was
outside so
i wasn't going to let nothing run over
me you know and in the same sense that
energy got to be in the music otherwise
people will applaud it a little bit you
know what i'm saying like oh good stuff
you're cool you know
but they're not gonna champion it
because it's when you show them
when you show them both sides of
yourself the the the angry side the
upset side the vulnerable side when you
show them all of that then people feel
like he doing it for us because they
know that don't you don't stumble on
that you got to push to that you know
so the way the album came about
like
right when they announced that the tour
wasn't gonna happen and we no longer
prepping for tourists like
i'm at home bro like right it's a weird
moment for all of us i'm at home yeah
like hey man send me beats bro yeah send
me beats and the first song i did
uh off
warren wonders is shame on you oh wow
you know what i'm saying summer in the
winter time so it's february it's just
after no it's march the month after
black habits was done
summer in the winter time smoke back on
this bee act like it's dinner time full
packs no receipt no low jack on my heat
in case i have to throw that in the
river after center time i'm good i'm
good i swear i'm good i ain't losing no
sleep i'm hood i'm wood i'm where i want
to be see no defeat i pull that off the
hip to shoot the [ __ ] to piss the
vultures off the coaches in good hands
god damn that man is so in sync you know
what i'm saying just like
talking my [ __ ] purely like i'm here
give a [ __ ] if we can't go on tour if
you know what i'm saying if we reach we
hit what we think is like a goal
and then we find another like detour
that we got to take i'm still here so
some of this music is [ __ ] i got to tell
myself like hey man talk your [ __ ] smoke
you know because i remember listening to
early jay-z not early jay-z like minute
away jay-z
and uh
from the outside critics were saying oh
he braggadocios this and that and the
other but i was at the time when i'm 17
listening to it it's like that's the
[ __ ] i need to say about myself when i'm
walking through the city to feel how i
need to feel to get past all this you
know what i'm saying i can't humility
don't get you past you know what i'm
saying your immediate circumstances it's
that sometimes irrational sense of
heightened self that'll have you you
know
confront challenges head on and overcome
the [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying so
that's why like i don't apologize people
know i'm a humble person based on my
interaction with them
[Music]
and in the music too they're they're
very intentional moments where you give
people just lessons yeah i'm a teacher
but but in order for them to care about
those at all you got to just take the
gloves off and sometimes hey man i
always say this like the greats like you
know if we think of kendrick right think
about that control freestyle i shouldn't
i don't even think that [ __ ] came out
on the control verse right it wasn't
even freestyle but i don't think that
song ever officially came out it just
like leaked on the blogs
and
he would never think about that moment
how important that was
where he was like yo
nobody's [ __ ] with me
sometimes you gotta hey smoking on your
top five this is the most
low profile [ __ ] in the game
and out of nowhere smoking on your top
five like sometimes you gotta hit
[ __ ] in their mouth so they
respect you period
perry
nah for sure man that
uh yeah that's great uh so
you know i feel like
i saw the video right you go you you you
shot a lot of that when you were in
africa absolutely um
where where was uh like like time wise
when would when did you go to africa
i want to say march
february of this year february of 2021
right yes so talk about that trip
because that's kind of a interesting
time we're kind of like
mentally feels like we're over the
pandemic even though it's shit's still
hot you know what i'm saying but like
how was that trip man
um
that trip was
by the way first time there no that was
my second time in nigeria i had been to
abuja okay which is the capital i hadn't
been to lagos which is like the old
capital where it's way more history and
stuff right way more people in lagos
um
that trip was interesting man because
um one traveling during you know
pandemic time or whatever we want to
call this era
um
it's just it's a heavy lift you know
that like literally the airport
experience is a whole different
experience when you enter in another
country during that time so
it's damn near traumatic because it's
like
you know uh you're getting stopped a
million times i got threatened like
within the first within the first uh
15 minutes i got threatened to get
arrested because my mask wasn't over my
nose you know what i'm saying oh my god
it was below my nose and she was like
lift your mask above your nose
i was like okay for sure haphazardly and
i'm talking though so i'm talking and my
mouth is open and up and down like yeah
shanks we got this and then the other
discussing where we going what the plan
is
it come back down i got two bags in my
hand so i'm not thinking about it she's
like if i have to tell you this again i
am going to have you arrested
and i was like
i was like down smokey down like chill
out because i wanted to without you're
not yeah
i wanted to be like man i don't want to
have to sock on those security guards if
you'll have me arrested make sure the
real police come yeah because it's too
early the plane ride was too long
like we had already gotten stopped so
many times that i was it had it had to
be connecting flight right oh absolutely
we might have flying flowing through
london or something yeah
and so but of course
that was all going on in my head i
pulled up my mask and was all right and
it just what gets me is
they always got like they always got the
black people policing the black people
you know what i'm saying they got
somebody like my auntie telling me pull
up your mask you know what i'm saying
and i know she's just doing her job but
you know it just ends up in and and me
feeling violated like leave me listen
the world has gone
[ __ ] crazy the world is [ __ ] crazy
dude and i'm vaccinated right but like a
lot of the shaming and like the
[Music]
i like to call it caring [ __ ] going on
against people who aren't vaccinated is
so [ __ ] ridiculous absolutely it like
makes me sick like when i see people the
way talking about kyrie irving and [ __ ]
i'm like
yo like not like people have the freedom
to do what they want with their body
[ __ ] they want to
do whatever the [ __ ] and i'm vaccinated
yeah and i get the rummy the booster run
me all the shots [ __ ] it right yeah i
already got a [ __ ] microchip in my
pocket everywhere i go you know where
the [ __ ] i'm at i got i got two phones
you got kids yeah oh for sure but this
this this the world is going
crazy bro like definitively like crazy
like [ __ ] are so
you know it's crazy because as much as
trump divided us
it's coveted [ __ ] oh
it might be worse oh easy it's easy it's
wild bro i feel like we're in a movie
bro that's why it's it's a whole
different
planet it seems like
it's just
if you read there there are books
that were written long before this time
that talk about the
the dangers of
of
information like
information being controlled by
one central entity the way people
view one or
two right the way people view the world
the way
our opinions are so
fed and and you know it's so built into
our daily schedule whether it's tv
whether it's instagram
um
that we're not even aware that that our
opinions are being regurgitated it's
what we heard and we're kind of told to
believe you know what i'm saying and
people feel so strongly about them like
they came up with it you know what i'm
saying so i came up in a time where
critical thinking was encouraged just
something that's good like
ask questions because it it's only gonna
either get you closer to the truth or
give you a better understanding of
something that you didn't already know
but now
now we're in a time where the people who
ask questions are made to
seem like um
dangerous like the literal word
dangerous you're you're dangerous i mean
that's dangerous about nikki and i i saw
what nick like all the stuff nikki
tweeted and people acted like she killed
a baby on the internet
and i was like am i missing something
here right did she not say she'd get
vaccinated if she had to to go on tour
like
what the [ __ ] is going on right right no
no
the narrative is that
they whoever the [ __ ] they are
um would like for people to believe that
that
by
having
choosing to exercise your
uh ownership of your own body in in a
way that says
no or let me ask some questions here
or or at the at the end of the day it's
the no that bothers people
like no
it's you know yeah you know i mean the
ques i mean the questions are
are deemed as problematic as well
because you know
ultimately you want people to
to be able to be told what to do but we
getting too far into that [ __ ] like the
the reality is the world is [ __ ]
weird so should
people should feel comfortable being
honest
and
we talk about shaming when it comes to
women we talk about shaming when it
comes to you know what i'm saying but we
don't talk about it when it comes to
people who say i disagree
i feel like
like we are in an era where
everyone is shamed if they don't go for
the status quo for anything socially
right and it's like
you know you can't have any independent
thoughts without being boxed into one
one
world right like it's like hey if you
you either think and agree with me on
every issue
or you're
this or you're dangerous or you're
dangerous or you're a piece of [ __ ] or
you're
whatever the [ __ ] it is where it's like
what happened but but the the powerful
part is
i come from a school where as soon as
people start trying to make you out to
be something
like i
i you know what's that song i'll be
there yeah
i'm dangerous yeah let's be right
dangerous you know what i'm saying one
time you know ex
was like oh she was mad at something i
did and and and it was just it was like
a brief like brief little relationship
we was trying something it didn't work
you know and in my book i'm like hey it
didn't work we can be cool because we're
grown and it's respect
but she started calling me on my name
like
this you this
i was like hey you know i'm not sure
what you're used to
but once you think that about me you're
you're free to walk away you don't have
to call me names just don't call me you
know what i'm saying and then she kept
calling me names but calling me to call
me names so i was like how about this
i'm him i'm that guy you know what i'm
saying if you want to call me [ __ ] [ __ ]
if you want to call me something i'm him
now
exactly save me as that in your phone
yeah so if you ever pick up the phone to
call me know that you're calling him
and you got to feel some kind of way
about that yeah we talked about you you
know having a gun illegally and and and
like the gun thing
or or or semi i don't know the
complications of having a gun isn't
a legal owner of a firearm no i mean
when you were talking about moving i
don't know yeah well we talked about the
complications of being a legal firearm
owner here in california in california
there we go gotta have the [ __ ] clip
in the trunk gotta you know exactly
shit's [ __ ] what i was about to say
by the time you [ __ ] go get the clip
out of your trunk you're [ __ ]
dangerous
but what's crazy is like my whole life
i've been i wouldn't say an anti-gun
person but i never gravitated towards
guns but i never really understood like
i kind of have evolved on the issue
since i moved here yeah
because i'm like yo it's low-key really
hard to protect yourself out here right
it's like and and what we talked about
earlier like when i say that to certain
people they look at me like i'm a
[ __ ] mega person or something because
i'm like yeah no i think we should be
able to have guns but like
period and it eliminates the assumption
on one person's part that that makes you
automatically more powerful than the
next
it i think in a certain way because
i think in a certain way
it it gives people it just levels the
playing field right and i also believe
in if you if you're a gun owner you also
need to be ready and willing to remove
yourself from a situation still exit of
course still of course be very you know
very well tempered and mannered exactly
just because you have a gun that's not
that does not give you a reason to react
any differently than you would react to
any other situation i also think you
should go through a background check to
make sure you're some crazy [ __ ]
absolutely but this don't make you
bulletproof 100 but but i do i'm like
you know we think about like
you know on this side of la right now
like you know west hollywood melrose
[ __ ] is hot out here like i don't know
if you see the video the guy in the
mellow ball jersey where they try to run
up and rob him and he had a gun
three kids ran up on this dude and his
girl
and they didn't know this dude was
strapped too
and so they ran up on him guns out he
turned around and lit them up
they never found the guy the guy who
actually shot that but it's all on video
and they're like we're trying
and only in california will that guy
probably go get in trouble for
protecting us right it's documented it's
all right it's documented that his life
was in death
yes and he was acting in self-defense
hey what up man we got to interrupt the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at odd socks now when i be
riding for odd socks so hard man it's
because i really love the product they
got the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world i got a pair of odd socks
basics on right now go get those they
got the socks wwe joints you know i'm
saying shot to the undertaker pepsi
[ __ ] really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you got to go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview uh talk about getting
nominated for best rap album of the year
and best new artist of the year which i
even think is a bigger deal because
that's a much harder category to crack
right as a rapper
um what was your like tell me like just
you know obviously that's a
life-changing moment to get absolutely
that when you wake up in the morning you
know i know how those grammy mornings
are when they announce the nominations
it's super [ __ ] early it's east coast
time like what was that like man we were
going to the gun range ironically enough
we were going to the outdoor gun range
where you know you could have multiple
people in our section we are shooting
down
you know down the lane and
my mama was gonna come all kind of
people it was just a hot day
and um
i'm actually in the car and we get the
call
it's like you nominated and we we had
grown accustomed to being
up for consideration so i'm like
i'm like okay nominated like we got the
actual nomination or like or in
consideration for the next stage of
inconsiderate like no you're have a
grammy nomination you're like you're
gonna be at the grammys
like what you mean right you know and
then i'm like oh [ __ ] like that like so
it
it hit us we got excited
and um
and it kind of that's another time where
our little plans got derailed because we
already had
what we thought was going to be a
project it wasn't called war and wonders
at the time
we're planning on dropping something
late 2020. um
you know like we're gonna hit him in
february we're gonna hit him again you
know and then that happened so it's like
okay well until the grammys happen this
is it's still black habits season you
know
and uh
but so getting getting nominated for
best rap album
um
i think it speaks a lot to
to
for early for early project for me to my
storytelling ability for it being a
cohesive body of work
and um
for having a very
clear identity among the rap albums that
came out then
um
i think for best new artists of course
it spoke to the body of work but that
spoke to
my my my new presence in this world you
know what i stand for how i show up the
music that i put out the visuals behind
it i think it's just like
people saw saw me as
uh somebody that came in and filled the
void not just on the musical front but
on the like
you know i come from you know i grew up
in the 90s right so we had tupac out
there being vocal across different
boundaries it was
you know i was a tupac fan more than i
was a tupac music fan you know what i'm
saying like when tupac was in a movie it
was it was dope right more impactful
movie when tupac spoke about an issue
you wanted to listen
and then when he put out something you
know you wanted to learn it too you know
you know your body is banging baby i
love the way you're flying it time to
give it to daddy sugar to tell me how
you know what i'm saying like you feel
that like because you believe them you
know and i think when we put out music
people believe
like what i say and where i'm coming
from and they want to know more so i
think that worked to our advantage uh if
you ask me i'm putting out better music
right now i agree you know better music
i love black habits but you know we were
learning we're learning in front of the
world and that's cool i love when that
happens you know i want the world to see
me grow so
everything is going how it's supposed to
um but i we were i was a little
surprised to keep it 100 i was giving
myself to the third project because i
made black habits to tell a very
specific story this is my family story
and a project when they go back to my
first album i want them to find black
habits
about jackie ron and their three sons
ron getting locked up big bro being from
families but looking out for his young
younger bros i want that story to be
what they find you know pop's coming
home right
and being a great father i want them to
find that whole narrative
so
with that being like the introduction to
a long essay or to a novel i didn't
expect you know what i'm saying to get
recognized that way um if it was i i
kind of expected bet to be the ones you
know what i'm saying like yeah like blue
rest of the year exactly yeah i feel
like they had categories for that
um
but it kind of speaks to because the
grammys it's not just the black
community voting it speaks to
the the crossover appeal of my story and
what i represent when i stand up and and
either rap speak or just show up you
know and and i was proud to have that
moment but as you can see
what's more important to me is we're
here to stay and they got to see that
every time we put something out it's
worth being respected it's enjoyable
and uh we pushing boundaries so what
were you i mean obviously you know i
always say this i do think that the
pandemic did help
people enjoy lyricism again because
there wasn't no clubs to be standing on
couches
there was all that [ __ ] was out the door
[ __ ] was listening at home in
their headphones or in their car on f or
or running or whatever people were
listening to music a lot differently and
i think that the best rap album
nominations really reflected
uh
a scope of music that was like
kind of like
showed us where we were for the last
year people were listening differently
yeah black um
like
i can imagine doing an album that's like
all talking my [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying and a time like that it kind of
bites you in the ass like
um
people would get mad it's like we're
dealing with realer stuff i think it's
seasoned even the casual listener to
want
just a little bit more you know yeah
yeah for sure man
but of course i i enjoy all kinds of
music so even
even from like who people understand is
like the somewhat conscious educator
dude it's like man music serves multiple
purposes so i don't know none of you but
2020 was a time where they were like
okay who's
actually able to speak to
what's going on and if not speak to
what's going on say something that
that at least um
has some semblance of
truth and honesty and real storytelling
is if you think of the nominees it was
alfredo
black habits royce
shout out to royce for finally getting
one
uh king king's disease i'm missing one
chica oh yeah jay electronics i know
chica was best known
it was like yo these are all like this
is all bars lyricism straight up yeah
and it was just like yo whoever wins is
like a win for the culture
i knew it was going to be nice
i told you i i was like get better
and i'm nominated but i'm like all right
if i take it home i knew i was going to
feel some kind of way like oh [ __ ]
because i saw one because it's like
you ever seen a boxing match
where
two fighters bang it out and one is
famous
oh real famous and and he kind of gets
whooped a little bit but you know he
smiles and raises his hand after the
fight too like yeah i won and we like
know the [ __ ] you did
and then they announced uh
this dude you know the popular one wins
you know
they the look on their face always tells
the story like you had thanks but it's
like damn you know i loved king's
disease i didn't think it was the best
album in that category but i knew he
would win because
nasa's never won a grammy it's his time
it's his time man he he deserves i wish
they should could retroactively give
nomadic
it was written and you know all that so
i was like yo like now is the time for
them to do right by nas like it's kind
of like all that time leonardo dicaprio
never had an oscar right and then he got
one for the revenant and it was like
there's other roles he probably should
have got but right right but he deserves
just give him a [ __ ] he's leo he
deserves a [ __ ] oscar nas needs a
grammy absolutely who won um best new
artist i don't uh make the style
shout out to megan shout out to me meg
had a [ __ ] year for sure man
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you had to pick a
winner outside of
black habits for
in your opinion what was the best album
now who deserved to win like you know
obviously we can say nas you know it was
a good look for knowledge to get it i
like i like
i did like king's disease a lot
i also like uh
i also like the not what is it not the
algorithm uh
[Music]
actually was tight as hell and i'm just
talking about like royce is a beast man
it flowed he wrapped his [ __ ]
ass off you know what i'm saying i said
algorithm but allegory was hard it was
fire i put it on and ran
when i was living downtown couldn't do
much but i put it on and ran
and was just gone it was just good to
see him get that nomination too man
because he's one of the all-time greats
like lyrics lyrically
he's he's your rapper's favorite rapper
top tier yeah i feel like him lupe
there's like a few guys who are like
absolute master level alien mcs who just
don't get the respect and like
and royce is one of those guys
absolutely shout out to royce so um with
this project you have john legends on
the album your brother's on the album
boogie's on the album uh marchand
brochures on the album
uh
not i mean really i want to say outside
of boogie was that the soul hip hop
feature
uh uh toby nui oh okay
he's incredible incredible yeah genius
he's i [ __ ] love that dude a true
artist yeah his his visual just
everything about his aesthetic the [ __ ]
he'd be saying is so ill
and it's just and it's so direct and
like
yeah
why has nobody ever said this like this
before period
and unapologetic like he's from is he
from houston yeah yeah
yeah the houston niger boy he said some
[ __ ] like uh what was that recore he
said cause i throw hands what the [ __ ]
is yeah i try jesus don't try me cause i
throw hands like
come on bro
why has no one ever said that
come on try jesus not me
like you know toby's on there so we're
very selective and it's like toby's the
one one rapper because that's just my
bro i feel like our
position in life is so similar both
college graduates family men that are
just like have this strong sense of
responsibility to our family and a place
where we from
to
you know to be lyrical to challenge what
it means to be at the top because you
know he rap like he going for the top
seed
and but he still
he does so without compromising himself
there's a lot of mutual respect there
and then and then um westside boogie is
just like an alien he that's man
like on my underrated listen like and
and i didn't say him because he's on the
album but on my list of underrated
rappers and artists you know i saw him
perform before the world really knew
about him uh it was an event at uh the
adidas store in hollywood and this is
sir perform there too so i'm i'm back
there supporting sir right on a song and
and so the world don't even really know
what songs
i have where i'm featured on the search
song because it's on the early eps and
stuff
but i'm performing that with him and
then boogie get up and rip it
and and you got the you know the signs
of like oh there's some gang bang street
[ __ ] but i'm like oh [ __ ] he's a
lyricist
oh [ __ ] he he telling stories like like
boogie's dope you know so
um when we being selective i got all
kind of voices as singers and stuff like
that but when it comes to and musicians
really like my boy marcus paul playing
the horns on several songs um but when
it came to rappers it was like we're
gonna have a couple moments you know i
did reach out to yg you know what i'm
saying um we connected on you know on
several things from a community van we
keep just running into each other but
for this project it didn't happen so you
know we went ahead and moved forward
tell me if this is right or wrong i
don't know why i keep hearing focal are
you having a record with cardi b tucked
um
no comment okay
in my opinion that means yes
i'm gonna say no comment because if i
say no if i say no i'm also saying it's
not supposed to happen that's fair okay
i see i see you it could be it could be
a yes it could be a no but i'm gonna say
no comment um i look forward to
to reconnecting with cardi though you
know what i'm saying it's been a minute
since we we got in you know well i mean
there that's another thing rhythm and
flow season two was gonna happen and
then the pandemic happened yeah and i'm
sure you would have made an appearance
in some capacity yeah i would have for
sure showed up and be like hey you would
have been like a guest
a guest judge for an app for an episode
or something like the la episode like
hey we gotta guest judge d smoke right
right i remember when i was there you
know but no um you know if they need me
when they when they're pulling up i'll
show up for them but i don't know when
and if that's going to happen so
we in a different time you know how um
how hard is it to find
people who can make your visuals come to
life
um you've done a good job of finding
those people i'd like to point out but
man like your videos are so
amazing like i think that the
the the bigger question is what is the
real effort what role does the artist
play in making sure that videos come out
how they want you know um
you look at people's work and you see
it's like do they have a certain quality
a caliber of it then you add your vision
and your attention to detail to
their experience and capabilities and
then you you're gonna have your video
it's just
i don't think a lot of
artists know what it means to
uh
be be very active in that process you
know from from
looking at the small details of what the
shot list is
to in the treatment like
like no i don't want to do this you know
i say no a lot yeah but i'm not gonna
just be like hell no i'm gonna be like
no what about this let's try this and so
and
working with like sergio who's
incredible who did all the nip stuff
it's like we have developed a chemistry
where it's like
he we communicate like expecting both of
us to have feedback you know because
i'll shoot a video director
a uh
uh
an idea that's super underdeveloped but
it'll give them a sense of direction
okay where to go
yeah you know what i'm saying for
example when i worked with child on the
honey jack video great video i love that
video and so i might be my favorite one
it's so good yeah it's a little movie
you know i told her i want to do jazz
club in the
20s or you know 30s or something
and uh and then
i told her i want to be like working in
the club and
drinking and by the end i step up drunk
every detail in between like from the
bus to this like yeah where do you find
that bus
she did she
child is a genius and her whole team is
dope you know child and nancy and um
and so it's always a pleasure to work
with them
um
but but yeah so it just depends on it
it's like the artist having an idea of
what they want to do and how they want
to be portrayed you know
like i know we would we had talked
before how you were reinvesting a lot of
the early money you were getting after
the show into the into your videos like
into your into the project into your own
[ __ ] right like absolutely i'm assuming
you know this is probably
you may be true i don't know when you i
know you you ended up getting with
empire relatively soon after the show
yeah we we shot that video
we shot that the
first video and another video on our own
dollar so we shot no commas on our own
dollar we shot uh
uh
honeyjack on our own dollar you know and
put together other materials around the
rollout prior to getting with empire so
by the time empire came along you had a
lot of it already ready to go it was
teed up
yeah we had stuff ready to go and that
was that was key because um
we were we were in negotiations we
didn't just talk to empire we talked to
you know what i'm saying we talked to
colombia we talked to
uh def jam i think we talked to motown
i'm sure everybody i mean everybody was
trying to sign you yeah they were trying
to sign us for sure but you know it was
it was too early for them to sign us to
what we wanted to be signed to right
you're not going to give up
i always tell everybody don't never sign
too [ __ ] early man because then you
end up with the shitty terms you might
have an advance but you better make that
[ __ ] last cause you ain't getting no
money off your music ever exactly hell
of a business person well that's smart
man i mean i think that that's something
too like what i was gonna say was like
you investing in your own [ __ ] and
making sure your visuals were top tier
before you had
you know all of this
i wouldn't say you had some notoriety
based off the show but as far as having
like respect respect and and all that
like you know a lot of artists wouldn't
do that you know a lot of artists might
go get a rover or something or or or you
know put their money anywhere outside of
themselves and their craft i could have
bought a bentley yeah cash
cash not been able to afford the oil
change so you took the money from
winning the show and pretty much just
parlayed that into your own [ __ ] right
absolutely absolutely
and you know said put something to the
side you know and but the rest of it we
invested
chipped off my team chipped off my mom
and pops you know what i'm saying you
know i hear kick back a little bit
mm-hmm
um and we just kept working
would you and your brother ever do a
joint project together hell yeah hell
yeah we look forward to it that's got to
happen we look forward to it has that
has it been discussed
absolutely we've had some conversations
we've had some conversations
just got to get top dog to sign off on
it i'm sure he'll do that no problem oh
yeah todd i mean tapas
he's he's not one to stifle
creativity or ideas he's like how can we
make it happen you know what i'm saying
so yeah that wouldn't even be an issue i
know you had um
gone on the road with your brother
before
and obviously uh him being a part of
one of the biggest operations in hip hop
td like what what are some things that
you saw
as a spectator
kind of behind the curtain of what tde
does that you've learned and kind of
applied to d smoke absolutely um
tde employees don't give nobody no
passes
like if it's not right they own it and
i'm talking about these are nice people
you know what i'm saying tdd got some
gangsters and then they got some
scholars they got you know people see
top you know what i'm saying
but they got employees from different
backgrounds but
the culture of it is if it's not right
we're not accepting it you know and
so you know coming from like a the
regular workplace whether it be a school
where you're a teacher it's like i want
to be the agreeable person so it's like
no we'll be flexible i understand
there's none of that there's none of
that because when you show up
if you make it a a habit or if you have
a tendency to
give people passes like whether it be
the hotel stuff ain't right or you're
just not treating us right
you don't make a habit of giving people
money that ain't doing you right and but
when they treat you right and they take
good care of you then you have a contact
for a long period of time and you go
back to that business and you they take
care of the people that take care of
them if you're giving them if you
disrespect them because you think we
just some rappers showing up
like not that they're gonna go big but
they might go big in a very professional
way like okay we're not having a the
right conversation with the right person
let's talk to somebody else oh you that
person okay well since you're the top
person i want you to talk to my guy you
know what i'm saying who's the legal
person right because i'm feeling real
disrespected right you know however it
is
and
when that starts happening things start
to get real tight around your
organization and you show up with a
different level of confidence because
people
your reputation is that your your
expectation because your expectation of
yourself is high your expectation of how
people deal with you is high and if they
meet that then you are all good you know
there's no problems it's not like we're
looking for problems we're just looking
for perfection you know what i'm saying
so being on tour with them um it taught
me that it taught me that it's all hands
on deck it taught me that
it taught me business structure right
because
there's top dog but each artist has
their own day-to-day
one or two people then as a company they
have
people who are on multiple teams you got
somebody who might be on tour with
isaiah one
one
group of months and if isaiah's out off
cycle they'll be helping out with the
sur stuff you know what i'm saying
because i saw there was a uh
uh
part where matt you know matt shout out
to matt yeah
isaiah's guy yes yeah yeah matt came on
tour with us um and because for some
reason edgar you know couldn't do a
certain couple dates and um so then you
just see these people picking up slack
so now it's like okay
i want to structure myself like the
winning teams you know what i'm saying
if if i'm in a race i gotta have an
engine that the same winning car has
yeah otherwise you know i'm already i'm
already handicapped so
um it just taught me that ethic it
taught me to be gangsta about your [ __ ]
you know and not not
not unnecessarily not that you know
projecting acting tough gangster [ __ ]
it's none of that because it's that calm
like respect treat people with respect
but anytime people
are like careless in how they deal with
you it's addressed you know and
corrected if possible and if they
correct their self then you right back
on right boy like oh cool see i knew we
handled that you know so what was it i
mean obviously going with empire
where you're essentially still
independent you're still in your masters
you're you know you're in a great
situation
you know empire had two of the five rap
album of the year nominations you know
what i'm saying is
a major indie um
you know working closely with gazi and
nemo what's that like because i think
gaza and nima are
still somehow underappreciated in the
music industry
um
for for what we're doing gazia and nima
are extremely supportive but they're
supportive in a sense that they as as
very independent businessmen they can
see
where their help is needed or not so
they kind of just give us the green
light to go our go-to guy at empire to
really rally people is gentry shout out
to our guy gentry yeah so gentry is like
riverside gentry yes
i.e gentry out the wage entry
out the way buddy but no gentry is our
go-to guy gentry travels with us yeah
you know what i'm saying gentry is there
he's a strategist you know what i'm
saying gentry if the energy in the
building ain't right jen she's like hey
y'all like this smoke is still that
[ __ ] like the music he's putting
out and turning in stuff that he's not
putting on the project is still at this
at this level and um they know i'm gonna
do my footwork you know what i'm saying
um
this this rap [ __ ] ain't easy you know
what i'm saying so just to show up just
to keep showing up is a decision
but to me there's no there's no
alternate decision so when they put
something on the table that's going to
put us in the room i'ma show up you know
and it might be a hard night it might be
a long studio session prior to and i
might collapse when i leave a room but
when i walk in there they're gonna think
like i'm gonna be fully present yep you
know so and that's the confidence that
they have in me that that
that if if gentry has to go back to the
people and be like look let's let's put
some energy into this let's we need the
room around this you know
because just because you're signed
doesn't mean there's a certain level of
investment on other people's parts it's
a lot of moving pieces yeah a lot of
resources at
empire and it's real powerful when they
feel invested in it and they rally
around something and they've done that
for me last time and this time so you
know our first our first agreement was
for one project and then based on how
that was doing i was like hey i want to
do this again we was like let's go where
are we going yeah first one did great
yeah you know what i'm saying we got a
grammy now we got two grammy nominations
and it's a win-win it's a win-win
because they left me with enough to
uh
they left me with enough to be able to
uh
you know to to make money off what i'm
doing yeah have the freedom but still
have that support to be like bro we're
not gonna have you out here just
spending your money as it comes in all
the time we're gonna back you and we're
gonna put something together that's
mutually beneficial
you can still look yourself in the
mirror and be like i'm a man yeah yeah
yeah yeah not all contracts that's
important man
so important
how how long are we gonna have to wait
for the next album because i know you
said that there was gonna be one almost
right after black habits you were like
we're gonna drop this and then hit
upside the head and then the net you
know so so
it all depends on what the next album is
you know we got a lot of music
and so
it's crazy making music you love that
don't make the playlist you want to put
it out just because it's like i don't
want to hold it from you but then when
you also make working on a body of work
if it don't fit exactly in the track
list you're like okay well maybe we hold
on to this or you know pitch it for a
movie
you know what i'm saying or maybe in
five years we get d smoke's lost tapes
his version of lost tapes just keep
collecting or kendra you know where's
kendrick's untitled you know yeah yeah
stuff yeah untitled has some miles oh my
god
untitled hat get top on the floor come
on lost tapes was [ __ ] the first loss
tapes is
crazy oh blazer 50 exactly yes well
listen man the album is out go get it
um i'm sure you'll be rolling out some
more visuals soon absolutely we already
own it um and anything else that you got
going on you want to plug man any we're
going on tour of course the tour coming
to a city near you coming to a city near
you you just announced it right before
your board pull up on the yo go get your
tickets man all right go buy some merch
i like that i like the hoodie is that is
this a purchasable hood this is x this
is not purchased so one oh it's a one on
one
oh well there's that i gotta rock my one
on one but we got some stuff all right
man we'll go support the homie d smoke
appreciate it perfect